i couldn't i wasn't working she makes
you better that's good and she
created this podcast for me she created
it
she um made me go on auditions again
she made me um she really inspired me to
go out
is there a depression lying behind all
that stuff
you know there was a time where i was
deeply i still get really deeply
depressed and i you know
it's it you know with in light of social
media i compare myself to people yeah
yeah
comparing is the worst thing it's just
how to make yourself unhappy but yeah
not necessarily depressed
but but if you're i mean you've had you
know you expose yourself to a lot of
stuff and that can
hurt your brain it can leave you with
depleted neurochemicals and
you can end up with depression yeah it
just happens so you gotta get
okay but you know an addict who's not in
recovery when they need to be and i'm
not saying that every had it got to be
in
eternally you know what i mean you have
17 good years under your belt and some
of it was in the program so it wasn't
cool fine
but now things are changing and now it's
necessary
but an addict who is in their
non-recovering mode is always depressed
always
yeah you know that i think that's what
it is yeah at the
at the end of the day the the the
problem lies
in i'm an untreated i'm not ready to
call you untreated you're you're just
slipping
you're slipping and and you're just
slipping that's all i need to give you
just get back
get back yeah i am gonna get back yeah i
want to get back
and i'm not untreated do not don't do
that to yourself don't start beating
yourself up
you have a long amazing record in
recovery
and and you don't no one can take that
away from you that is yours
yeah and it just you know you got lazy
or whatever
depressed i don't know what and it's
slipping it's all right
happens it's a all the time yeah it's a
rare it's a very interesting time
uh i'm glad that we're talking about
this now because
there is a lot of things surfacing up i
can see myself there's
rage there's a lot of anger you can
you've seen it
are you nothing you've seen it are you
making her your higher power no
okay but he's seen it too we went to the
philippines together i have this
irritability not just aerodynamic i have
this rage
that's right at the surface and i can
feel it like i can feel it
was it was it here a few minutes ago
like a minute and a half ago
no no i i no because because i thought i
felt it
did you really maybe a little bit yeah
maybe a little bit but it wasn't
the way i felt toward him and the way i
felt toward her at times where she would
say something and i would have this
thing and i have to calm myself down
right
but i've never been like this in your
life
not in recovery i think that my first 10
years
of sobriety you know i had commitments
at meetings
so you know you know i don't know what
that is exactly but i can tell you how
the recovering community
talks about that they will say there's a
problem in the spirit
right there's a problem with the spirit
right now and
whether or not a spiritual program will
restore you i don't know
but there's a problem in spirit right
now
i i also okay just based on like my
observation
his lifestyle is very sedentary and i
tell him that maybe you want to be toned
i do
well let's work out let's get the jake
let's get going it's maybe not all the
root of his rage but maybe it could be
some type of
outlet trying to just lessen the tank a
little bit
range oh i like that yeah
yeah it it it's affected my addiction
to gadgets especially video games
because i played a lot
has not only affected our relationship
but it's also affected my career
gosh you know when when people i
obviously have a process thing for sure
but but when people really get going
down that path
i always worry about depression i always
feel like it's a way to
escape depression yeah depression yeah
so you would so you're as a therapist
and as a doctor
right your suggestion to me is to call
cut cold turkey cold jerky okay cold
jerky okay
i'm not your doctor and i'm not
functioning as they're
difficult
you're asking me these questions and i
have some professional expertise in this
area and so i'm giving you my
impressions okay
my impressions based on what i
understand to be happening
is you're slipping you gotta i think dan
would get you
get pull your chain right back up on the
ship you need to
get back in which you know is the right
series of the rooms to go into and
find your your piece again and then
in order to really be honest and open
and follow the direction of your sponsor
who you're going to find
they're probably going to tell you what
i'm telling you which is all that shit's
got to stop
and then we'll see what's going on yeah
okay so um let's
one foot i know you don't like it i knew
they're like just you don't like it
did you like stopping drugs when people
were trying to get you stopped drugs and
alcohol did you like
no but here's the thing though dude it's
like
when people would say i remember my
friend my friend the last time i
relapsed
my friend laban called me over to a
coffee he's like meet me at this coffee
shop and he
he gave me this mini intervention like
he's like yeah like i did
what you'll do like i did you did he was
like dude i can you're
slipping dude you're gonna die right and
i go [ __ ] you whatever i said you know
you know what you're talking about
and then four months later i hit a
bottom
and i got sober but i didn't do it maybe
late late
well maybe you're gonna have to sink a
little further here too
that's okay yeah i i'm not no i don't
want to but i won't judge you
i just know that's how this thing works
and you know how that's how it works too
how much you have to suffer how much you
can put her through
i don't want to do it you know but
here's some good news is that you know
we
we've been looking at houses and i have
a baby that's a perfect way to solve
problems like this really
no problem let's go
a guy that i haven't spoken to in 15
years ago
hey man it's me bob oh hey
what do i say like hey i just wanna i i
we well first of all you're going to
avoid saying anything hey just thought
of you i want to hang up see you later
bye
but you're going to have to say you know
i told a friend of mine about the
the powerful impact you had on my life
and i think i need a little bit of that
again right now
oh damn
no they're looking okay you're not gonna
hit me you're not gonna say that no i
wouldn't say it but you're not
jewish jewish
[Laughter]
yeah just a little taste a little taste
of it again just a little
bit you almost got me there dude but no
way not you [ __ ] nothing
i got [ __ ] i called him [ __ ] nod doctor
yeah we're just gonna go straight in
here
straight up you're not gonna get me
there remember that rage i told you that
really
hit home with me dude that really hit
home with me bro